I wanted to start by saying thank you to
an incredibly important person my
favorite part of our Pulitzer board
meetings is the moment at the end after
we've confirmed our decisions we take a
final vote reconfirming our selections
on everything and then sig Gissler says
great let's go sprinkle some fairy dust
and that's what we do and it is the most
wonderful thing to sprinkle the pulitzer
a fairy dust and sig has been an
extraordinary tender to the prizes over
the last 12 years we have relied on him
constantly for good judgment helping us
understand precedent helping us
understand procedure always keeping us
focused on the task at hand so everybody
in this room owes a debt of considerable
gratitude to sig Gissler so you can ask
you to stand for a moment so we could
thank you
you
Mary Gary Glen I'm so glad you could
join us and be here today thank you very
much greetings everybody ladies and
gentlemen president Bollinger what a
special and historic opportunity this is
what a great privilege and honor to
celebrate all the remarkably gifted and
passionate writers reporters artists
editors and publishers filling this
rotunda today we've gathered here to
celebrate you one another and our common
democratic enterprise as we begin though
I'd like to call your attention to a
small special book that's not otherwise
on our agenda it's called wild about
books don't worry I'm not creating an
impromptu Pulitzer I site this sweet
children's book by Judy Sarah as a sort
of parable the animals at the zoo get a
library and what a transformation it is
in no time at all they become poets and
novelists some of them literal bookworms
day today as our culture of reading
grows the joy crescendos the grand is
today comes when the zookeepers award
the zoo late' surprises how do I know
about those ooh lasers at home I've got
a four year old and a two year old they
love the book and as far as they're
concerned that's what I'm doing today in
New York doling out the zoo letters so
they are so excited for all of you
though they were hoping for selfies me
with hippos giraffes anybody wanna
volunteer crocodiles in all seriousness
who can think about kids without
thinking about the future in my case
being a political philosopher I can't
think about the future without thinking
about democracy and wondering what will
become of it will we keep it
what does it take to build and sustain
it Joseph Pulitzer wondered about
similar matters and the prizes he
created are part of his attempt to
contribute to a solution in 1904 he
wrote our republic and its press will
rise or fall together for me the easiest
way to get at the essence of democracy
is to quote my favorite sentence from
the Declaration of Independence it's not
the one you're expecting instead it's
this one let facts be submitted to a
candid world the authors of the
Declaration began by asserting that when
in the course of human events it becomes
necessary for one people to dissolve the
political bands which have connected
them with another a decent respect for
the opinions of mankind requires that
they should declare the causes which
impel them to the separation the
colonists wished of course to separate
from Great Britain they believed that
they needed to give reasons
fundamentally their reason for
revolution was this that the history of
the present King of Great Britain is a
history of repeated injuries and
usurpations after they made this
allegation they laid out the content of
their investigative report a long list
of 18 grievances against the king they
introduced that list of grievances with
those words I love again to prove this
let facts be submitted to a candid world
but what is this idea of a candid world
one reads it in the Declaration and
feels nearly ready to dismiss it as the
romantic fantasy of a now lost era how
unfamiliar it sounds to our 21st century
ears when the writers of the Declaration
declare themselves bound by a decent
respect for the opinions of mankind to
present the causes of their action when
they say this they call out to the world
for judgment they call out there for to
a world that they expect will recognize
the value of judgment based on share
faqs and reason giving they call out to
a world that they believe has the
capacity to judge their actions fairly
this is the core idea of democracy
anybody and everybody can take part in
analyzing and interpreting the shape and
meaning of our world divining the
currents that are evident in the course
of events anybody and everybody can use
their findings together with good
arguments to forge the collective
decisions that will provide our best
bridge to a decent future yet in our
current circumstances this idea of a
candid world must sound it must have
sounded even to those of those
revolutionary times hopelessly utopian
indeed the writers of the Declaration
hedged their claim they qualified it
they wish to convey they say a decent
respect for the opinions of mankind they
recognize that human beings have an
inherent capacity for judgments about
fairness but to think that all people
everywhere always judge fairly would be
far-fetched if not extravagant a decent
respect is a modest but fair level of
respect a decent respect entails no more
than expecting most people to judge
fairly most of the time as Abraham
Lincoln may or may not have said you can
fool all the people some of the time
some of the people all the time but you
cannot fool all the people all the time
get even with this qualification the
writers of the Declaration can still
sound implausibly optimistic if not
naive can we still as a culture claim to
be in possession of anything like that
decent respect for the opinions of
mankind in fact I believe that everyone
who is joined in this room today is in
possession of such respect if anything I
believe that is why you are here the
power of your work an article and
SI a photograph a poem or a book
emanates from your philanthropic stance
toward your audience indeed toward
humankind you believe that we your
readers have the capacity to assimilate
to respond to and to judge your picture
of the world you to call out to a candid
world to address oneself to a candid
world however is to do far more than to
act on a belief in a core human capacity
the authors of the Declaration did not
so much describe the world known to them
as set a marker for an aspiration a
candid world is achieved not received it
is not a gift from on high but the work
of minds self-consciously applied in
presenting their facts to a candid world
238 years ago the writers of the
Declaration sought to call such a world
into being they were making a demand of
their audience which was made up not
just of inhabitants of the colonies the
global public too they were asking this
audience to achieve a new standard of
political decision-making in the
declaration they show their audience the
rudiments of that activity the
declaration of principle the
consideration of facts relevant to those
principles the discernment of meaning
and contemporary situations the proposal
of response to those circumstances all
this work was to be done together with
others and is far more relevant to all
of us today than you might think the
goal was that public choices should be
fairly forged in a crucible of public
opinion perhaps we will never achieve a
truly candid world but I remain
convinced that these are still the
elements necessary even to approximate
it can these ruminations on the
declaration help us understand Joseph
Pulitzers aspirations and ambitions for
the prizes he created he continued his
1904 thoughts on democracy thus
and you'll know these words an able
disinterested public spirited press with
trained intelligence to know the right
and courage to do it can preserve that
public virtue without which popular
government is a sham and a mockery a
cynical mercenary demagogic press will
produce in time of people as bases
itself the power to mold the future of
the Republic will be in the hands of the
journalists of future generations how do
we in the world room where the Pulitzer
board gathers judge texts against
Pulitzer as high standard well let's
take the declaration as our sample it
predates the prizes of course but it can
serve for an afternoon's parlor game we
can start by confirming the declaration
would have been eligible after all it
was published in newspapers throughout
the fledgling country so how would it
have fared I suppose that would depend
on the category in which it was entered
it probably wouldn't have done terribly
well an investigative reporting the list
of grievances against King George is
comprehensive it rests on deep reporting
and it provides a compelling account of
tyranny we never do hear from the other
side and we can easily identify
hyperbole in some of the grievances the
list was not really intended to be an
investigative report after all as John
Adams put it posterity must hear a story
that shall make their ears to tingle
maybe editorial would have been a better
fit they're the test of excellence is
clearness of style moral purpose sound
reasoning and power to influence public
opinion the declaration would surely
have been a strong contender in that
category as to its suitability for
public service I leave that to you to
judge our deliberations in the world
room are the most intense forthright
rigorous and collegial of any I've ever
been privileged to be a part of
and yet for my raiment academic so that
means something they have to be polite
sir has given us a demanding task our
charge is to select those exemplary
cases of journalistic literary and
artistic excellence whose bright light
helps us all pick out the path toward a
healthy Republic in my eight years on
the board I have been overwhelmed by the
intellectual power and moral integrity
exhibited by our contenders they you
that is give us reason to hope yet I
also think it is time for anyone with a
public audience to redouble her efforts
his efforts to cultivate a candid world
as I now reflect on the future that lies
before my children I am struck above all
that they were born in this early 21st
century world the post-september 11th
World for them there is no before and
after just this what we know now with
its ever-present culture of security ten
days after September 11th I was obliged
to give a speech to the incoming
freshman class at the University of
Chicago with them too i invoked the
declaration of independence and its
commitment to moving toward the future
as if in a candid world I celebrated the
aspiration to ask the most of humankind
my concern at the time was that under
pressure in the face of Terror we might
come to view our openness our civil
liberties our commitment to educating
all comers what you might call our
democratic magnanimity as one reason for
our vulnerability I was concerned that
we would need to work hard to preserve
our core democratic commitments at the
time i wrote a democracy is not weak for
opening itself to the world nor for
allowing its citizens great liberties to
the contrary it is not merely that
openness and rights make us who we are
as Democrats they also make us strong
for they alone inspire the consent
Allegiance and commitment on which
Democratic power rests
democratic authority rests on the
state's securing a way of life that we
are glad to share and on nothing else
now in 2014 13 years later I realized
that the question is not whether we can
preserve Democratic commitments but
rather whether we can rebuild a
commitment to a candid world almost from
scratch for all those who have been born
in this world who have never known
another can we teach them as the authors
of the Declaration once did what a
commitment to a candid world looks like
can we help them I wonder embrace this
ideal of fresh how do we rest a candid
world from the morass of deception
self-promotion and demagoguery that
comes to us at all levels and pervades
our institutional structures both in
this nation and around the world as
alarmist or even despondent as that
might sound I'm not without hope for we
have methods which are tried and true
deep reporting in pursuit of the truth
effective writing in pursuit of insight
and edification and unflagging advocacy
of a culture of reading and not merely
of watching and listening reading simply
and unequivocally is the most efficient
way to deepen and broaden understanding
I think Joseph Pulitzer was right when
he said an able disinterested public
spirited press with trained intelligence
to know the right encouraged to do it
can preserve that public virtue without
which popular government is a sham and a
mockery to sit around the world room
table and to debate your work is to have
one's optimism restored all of you in
this rotunda wield with sublime mastery
those tools of reporting and writing you
are to a person potent advocates for a
culture of thoughtful reading we are
counting on you to build that candid
world we are counting on ourselves to
emulate you to follow along the path
you've lit up
and now if you'll pardon the expression
let's give out those zuit sirs so
president Bollinger